new spider-man three details coming our
way
a hint at flaw from the channel the
cosmic wonder anyway listen swing into
this get it it's waiting how's it going
everybody it's Warren welcome back to my
channel the cosmic wonder where we talk
about all things relating to Marvel and
everything relating to the MCU that you
have some spider-man 3 news and this
news is actually coming from Sony
Pictures and Hyundai the car company I
know that probably sounds kind of weird
but as you've probably noticed Marvel
Studios usually partners up with a car
company for their films Iron Man's
outtie is a great example the Audi that
Captain America showed up to Iron Man's
cabin in and Avengers in game was a
great example as well and the decked out
Chevy Tahoe that Nick Fury drove and
Captain America the Winter Soldier is a
great executive on the movie sandy
struck a deal with Hyundai for their
cars to be in spider-man 3 and the cars
will be in the movie in a very specific
way so we'll break down the surreal they
talk about what it means if you're new
be sure to subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date on every this week's a
story can start from as follows Hyundai
Motor's new models and technologies will
star in five upcoming Sony movies
including uncharted the sequel to
spider-man far from home the sequel to
spider-man into the spider verse and
other 10 folsom to be determined and it
goes on to say the deal will marry Sony
Pictures IP with Hyundai's technology
and designs specifically bring into life
the automakers human-centered future
mobility vision which is dedicated to
revitalizing cities and galvanizing
urban air mobility the partnership will
leverage Sony Pictures iPhone for
marketing content and immersive
entertainment collaborate on
infrastructure and vehicular concepts
for Sony movies co-create virtual
reality and gaming experience and
co-produce events among other
opportunities Hyundai will also offer
substantial marketing support so what
does this mean and why do we really care
about the plot of spider-man 3 at the
end of spider-man jay-z revealed
spider-man's identity as Peter Parker he
also pinned him
as a murderer and we know from the
morbius trailer that the population
views him as a murderer so as many
people have predicted he's going to be
on the run and it sounds like Hyundai is
going to help with that Peter Parker is
used to having technology in fact one of
the coolest scenes from far from home
was where Peter was in Tony Stark's
plane making his new spider-man suit
well it sounds like Hyundai is kind of
going to fill that role here because we
know that Peter is going to have some
sort of help and oh I just get abandoned
by everybody who loves him specifically
happy and pepper there's no way that
they're going to believe that he killed
Mysterio and tried to murder a bunch of
people so they're definitely going to
help him out and it sounds like they may
be given him a super advanced car one
that will have a lot of technology and
one that will probably involve a lot of
chase scenes but from what report from
deadline says it doesn't sound like
they're going to be your ordinary chase
scenes the report says that Sony is
going to bring Hyundai's technology and
designs and the automakers
human-centered future mobility vision to
the screen they also said that they're
going to have very immersive
entertainment so we know that spider-man
is going to be on the run we know that
he's going to have some help from
somebody and start technologies and it
sounds like this car could probably play
a big part in him getting around without
being detected
and once he is detected we're probably
going to get a few really good chase
scenes in the movie involving Hyundai
this lines up perfectly with everything
that we know about the film spider-man
being on the run running away from the
authorities because again we know from
the Morbius trailer that people believed
Mysterio's video people do think that
Peter Parker is spider-man and that he
killed Mysterio so essentially a good
amount of the movie is going to be a
chase and it sounds like Peter Parker is
going to have a very advanced car to
help him get away throughout the film
and that car is going to be provided by
Hyundai and of course Stark Industries
in the movie but let me know what you
think about this now it's gonna be hot
it's super involved there's a better
manager
the executives on everything relating to
spider-man 3 you can follow me on
Twitter for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof I want more car based
announcer movie boy I love the car
sponsorship stuff in movies I mean are
there people who actually like I've
never met the person who's done that who
has like seen Iron Man and went I'm
gonna get an Audi - you know I've never
met that actually I've never heard of
that with any product placement in any
movie they put in the supercars you
could never afford so you'd be left like
I'm gonna get an Audi just not that
you're super rich what's what is the
product placement return that they're
hoping to gain I'd say is it like just
that's a small handful of people who
have the money to go damn Tony Stark has
an RA I'm gonna get in our time you
could trace that back to really working
is with James Bond and Aston Martin's
because I had years to solidify that
relationship but does it do anything now
you know other than add to the ubiquity
of people knowing the Hyundai name I
honestly couldn't tell your system touch
this thing I mean Hyundai is a lot more
affordable than an Audi though yeah I
mean it was if we look at it in terms of
plot points he is going around in a
Hyundai it's it's a much more it's less
conspicuous you know like it's easier to
blend in you're not drawing attention
with a Hyundai last thing I expected who
is this to be the report okay is this
gonna be another like start Technol
that's what warm was talking about this
video right is that there's gonna be
another start technology like vehicle
perhaps I don't know how I feel about
that I don't I don't know if I like that
idea though if we're I mean all for a
cool chase scene why not but spider-man
to a Peter Parker in a car that just
doesn't sound all that appealing to me
I'm like if I talk about chasey and it
would spider-man you should be on foot
tree rooftop chases we have swinging
not driving in a car I'll be slinging
the car around the city my arm out the
window just really using that super
strength that's the thing too is like
are they gonna introduce new Hyundai
features that they there's really be
available on the market let's tribute
them to Tony Stark or something in the
movie when they talk about this you know
human based driving view that they're
gonna introduce part of me goes that
could be a cool sci-fi thing but the
other part goes are they gonna wedge a
commercial into this movie or is this
gonna be their way of testing out some
technology and seeing how the public
responds I mean that's what it sounds
like to me it's even kind of funny that
they're doing this Hyundai thing to be
segue into into the spider-verse point
you can do anything
yeah I don't know what that'll do I
don't know is Kartika because there's so
much money damage maybe that's gonna be
the new kind of approach to advertising
as maybe they're gonna go with that like
you can be just like in this movie you
can have the fantasy car and it's
affordable even though it's got all
these crazy features and now you can be
Peter Parker right just in your car we
came here for spider-man news of like
the plot and such and weirdly in my main
takeaway if we're gonna get this Hyundai
deal is actually the one where it seems
I can make the most sense is another
video is not as long people are here for
but the whole race the most sense is the
Uncharted part because there's a lot of
car chase there's stuff that you could
do with that chart it's so actually
having a bitchin unday that makes the
most sense to it get some promotional
material limiter or heck even do black
panther because at least there is a
dedicated portion of that movie to
technology we're designing that is
futuristic and advanced and maybe
Wakanda has to you know outsource and
make some deals with hunting to make
that possible I mean I don't think
people want and more I feel like a
common complaint that is often thrown
with these latest reiteration of
spider-man like grin like people love
them and people love Tom Holland a
Spider Man sure absolutely he's
constantly being aided with
technological advancements from like the
star tech I mean that was one of the
cool things about far from home is the
way when that ends he's still using it
but at least he's putting together
himself he's at least doing that this
I think what people really want is to
get rid of it and go back to like more
of a just grounded spider-man where it's
just like red and blue suit spider-man
and he's on the run butter man's not
James Bond with like a million gadgets
yeah they're sure it's not a big deal I
would love it if this is not at all what
it is this is just another thing where
we're reading way too much into this
report and it's just like a snippet of a
scene like how most of these tend to go
it's so brief the Audi on Iron Man
always stands out like they they really
showcase here you know maybe I'll get a
Hyundai now it's the most I've never
been compelled to buy a car like we've
talked so much about of bring it on day
no I think I want to get a Hyundai this
movie is gonna be like one long SNL
sketch where they get the money for
product placement but they make a long
joke but I'm like I don't want to see
spider-man in a car chase him driving
behind the wheel or maybe it's some
other character you know maybe maybe
it's a villain who's hunting him down
maybe it's like Kraven the hunter who's
in this car and he's a hyundai guy he's
doing the chili Palmer he's like I got a
low profile make this cool there better
be a whole scene at a Hyundai car
dealership that's where the fanatics
would work I think if they like went to
a Hyundai car dealership and some
comedian was like the car salesman or
something like that yeah like yeah bill
burr selling a car or something like
that Randall Park he's an Aldi and then
and we might want to get one of these
hundred plus you could get spider-man
like slinging a car at the villain or
what I am I would be cool oh my goodness
there we go we cracked it
or maybe it means where he is getting
his car like everything's fine and the
first thing he wants to do is buy a
vehicle you know it may know everyone
knows who he is if he could just swing
around town with his identity exposed
yeah he wants to live that normal life
just to keep you know related to the
people all right guys what do you think
of this Hyundai deal leave your thoughts
down below
wonder who should have covered the
spider-man in 20 in
and I'm Miguel O'Hara you know he's
gonna be driving some souped-up hot like
just gonna have a Toyota Camry yeah 399
the desolate area we're only the Camrys
that served our human view technology
subscribe to the real region is my
favorite video was shot in a long time I
love this see you guys soon